it was a big night on Dancing with the
Stars as one couple got the first
perfect score of the season and another
was sent home after an emotional
elimination first perfect score of the
season what does it mean to you guys
[Music]
like this is our time to like dip down a
little you know but like so nice like
the fact that Len is speechless we
didn't let hasn't even given us a nice
like he's done the seven days and he was
teasing me he was going like standing
over me I know I know and and what I
don't know if people know this but
somebody's one of the hardest dances so
I was for sure thinking this is probably
gonna be you to top yourself do you feel
an extra pressure now knowing that
you've got that perfect score so early
on I just I tell him though I say every
week like now this late is clear again
like from the people that have been
saved like yes the competition that's
left we start over again like you just
have to you can't kind of live in the
past at all and you can't get too
excited for the future you gotta stay in
like this present moment and take it one
step at a time on on this show you have
to are also to drive you crazy she told
me that from the second we met like one
step at a time and I understand it I'm
actually understanding it now
you know Nikki's like yep yeah I'm not
even going to think about tomorrow no
while Juan Pablo and Sheryl clearly had
a lot to celebrate there wasn't such
happy news for another dancing pair
become believing us is Nancy and Val the
heartbreaking elimination left Nancy
speechless
[Applause]
[Music]